la chronique de l'économie comme tous
les jeudis 7 avec vous quelques corps
mais bon soit la soirée évidemment on va
parler des femmes chefs d'entreprise
ceci est fort logique
et oui pour cette journée des femmes
nous allons parler des femmes dans le
monde 10 de travail et plus
spécifiquement des chefs d'entreprise
nous en recevons deux sur ce plateau
valérie rodrigue qui est directrice de
planètes langue un institut en fort de
formation lampard dont basée à
rambouillet et virginie fév et bonsoir
qui a lancé avec son associé en 2008
rollingbox une agence de communication
digitale situé à versailles alors dans
les yvelines 26% des artisans
commerçants et chefs d'entreprise
seulement sont des femmes
c'est peu valérie rodrigues que c'est un
chiffre final qui vous étonne
non pas du tout - quand j'assiste à des
on va dire des réunions de chefs
d'entreprise qui que ça parle aussi bien
par la cgpme ou même simplement gbm est
érigée par une femme qui est dirigé par
une femme et que je salue d'ailleurs
parce que elle et elle est très
dynamique de ce côté là pour la
promotion justement de l'entrepreneur de
l'entente ont fait d'entre eux n'a rien
au féminin et donc qui contribue
vraiment à nous promouvoir et oui non ce
m'étonne pas moi je fais plein plein de
jeux comme quand quand je postule pour
des dossiers on va dire de financement
ou autre que je me retrouve à des tables
c'est presque majoritairement qui me
regardent donc qu'est ce qu'il fait ici
alors on va parler un peu de votre
parcours il a un petit pic puisque ce
poste de directrice finalement c'est pas
quelque chose qui était prévu non il a
été cédé par un homme un bon paris
arrive
racontez nous en fait moi j'ai démarré
ma mamma
mon existence professionnelle on va dire
comme comme professeur de langue parce
que j'étais simplement c'est mon coeur
de métier c'est ce que j'ai ici en fait
mais avec toujours l'idée un jour
d'avoir ma propre école ça c'est clair
j'avais toujours pensé que j'aurais mon
petit truc à moi mon petit truc à moi
mais je rebondis pas sur petit truc à
moi mais est ce que cela sous-entend que
parce qu'on est une femme on peut penser
que petit truc à moi oui peut-être avant
une peut-être peut-être parce que et le
nassidji interne et nage déjà un gg 47
ans et on va dire que de mon temps enfin
mon époque déjà être chef d'entreprise
j'en connaissais pas autour de moi un
moyen pas spécialement d'un milieu on va
dire où il ya beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise justement enfin en
regardant on y repense virginie fait
vous fait une drôle de tête vous n'êtes
pas d'accord non jeu
je pense que chacun son point de vue
c'est vrai que j'ai jamais ressenti
enfin on en avait discuté j'ai jamais
ressenti une différence homme femme
c'est peut-être l'âge c'est peut-être
une génération différente et
effectivement mais voilà j'ai toujours
voulu créer ma société créée en étant
étudiante exactement l'année où j'étais
salarié je faisais mes cours du soir mon
master en marketing et en même temps
j'ai créé la société
je me pose cette question est ce que
dans votre famille il y avait des
gilbert surprise il y avait des chefs
d'entreprise ça aide
oui voilà c'est peut-être ça là où il
habitait bon allez on va dire que c'est
ça la différence c'est sa part ailleurs
elle a fait des études de marketing mois
ses études de langues et c'est tout à
fait autre chose pas du tout le même
milieu lui et on n'est pas on est
presque élevé pour être prof
et vous savez que dans le milieu de
l'enseignement et c'est une majorité
féminine la marque contre la parité
hommes femmes
elle est presque de 26 pour voilà donc
en fait simplement bon je suis embauché
en 96 à l'institut international de
rambouillet qui se crée qui reprenait
l'institut vous avez une française ravi
dvg il m'a tout de suite
je te dire comment plaire a reconnu tout
de suite en moi a certainement quelque
chose mais en tout cas il m'a proposé un
poste de direction pédagogique qui
consistait à créer en fait une équipe de
professeurs d'enseignement d'enseignants
de et de créer des programmes etc et on
va dire que en 2000
8 fin 2008 il a décidé un matin de me
donner est que c'est pratiquement comme
ça que ça s'est passé parce que j'étais
pas du tout préparés à prendre ce poste
à prendre ce poste vous passez de
salariés à xavi au mali dans un matin on
m'a dit voilà moi je j'arrête
est ce que vous voulez reprendre donc
j'ai eu que quelques jours presque
qu'elle allait on va dire quinze jours
pour prendre ma décision et me dire oui
je vais devenir chef d'entreprise
mais ça a été compliqué ce passage
mentalement oui parce que j'avais en
plus mais les salariés qui étaient
présents étaient mes collègues
donc il fallait non seulement que
j'assume d'être différente mais en plus
d'avoir à reprendre un tout avec des
gens
partager un certain nombre de choses ou
de les conversations très très très
spécifique de salariés on va dire
après quand on est un patron peut plus
dire ce qu'on veut quoi jean talon
exactement
alors vous donc à linverse vous avez
commencé en tant que chef d'entreprise
on peut revenir du coup un petit peu sur
sur cette création j'étais salarié avant
j'étais jeune j'ai fait toutes mes
études en alternance donc depuis mes 16
ans je travaille parallèlement à mes
études mais effectivement je me suis
lancé j'avais j'ai 26 ans 25
et le parcours effectivement j'avais
choisi de créer ma société dans quoi
c'était la question
et puis ça m'a pris en cours d'année
voilà d'avoir une idée au départ avec
mon associé ce qu'on était deux on a
lancé un réseau social sur internet et
il appelait bolingbroke sexy rowling
box.com voilà
c'était une très belle aventure pendant
trois ans et demi et puis ça a dû
s'arrêter pour des questions de
désaccord et que les organismes de
droits d'auteur en juin 2010 on a vécu
pas mal d'expérience on a beaucoup
appris et du coup on a décidé de
remonter une agence digitale directement
derrière donc on n'a rien fait mais en
deux semaines on a changé d'activité et
donc maintenant ça fait deux ans et demi
et ça marche bien ça marche très bien
mais ravi à vous votre statut de femme
vous pensez que c'est finalement un
atout tant que chef d'entreprise c'est à
dire qu'en fait de façon d'un point de
vue philosophique je pense que de toute
manière des difficultés entreprendre en
font c'est difficile c'est tous celles
et de plus en plus donc il n'ya pas y'a
pas de secret après des difficultés on
peut en avoir à différents niveaux et
dans des handicaps il ya plein de
handicap différent que ce soient
physiques ou mentaux je pense que j'ai
jamais considérer ça comme un comme un
frein jeux les plus pris comme un
tremplin j'ai utilisé peut-être les
faiblesses comme des forces et
aujourd'hui ça m'a mené là enfin moi je
en tout cas j'ai pas ce ressenti alors
je suis aussi
j'ai toujours vraiment mené ma barque un
peu librement comme vous dites que vous
êtes issu d'une famille de chefs
d'entreprise est ce qu'on vous a donné
des conseils précieux
oui c'est vrai que j'ai vu mes parents
conseils qui peuvent s'appliquer aussi
bien l'homme qui a une femme après tout
on m'a dit de se fixer des objectifs et
d'avancer par objectifs et pas regarder
là ça vaut un homme une femme c'est
pareil c'est bon pour les deux et puis
après on m'a appris aussi à me battre
d'extraire toujours le positif je pense
que c'est ce qui est important j'ai
voyagé pas pointer si j'avais dû me
freiner voilà j'ai eu un parcours j'ai
dû faire mes études en cours du soir etc
j'aurais pas pu en arriver là mais voilà
j'ai mis mes 80 heures par semaine que
je continue toujours c'est une vie à
conjuguer entre plusieurs activités je
suis formateur ce chef d'entreprise j'ai
écrit un livre j'ai pas mal d'activités
mais j'ai fait ce choix et j'en suis
ravie si demain je voudrais faire un
autre choix moins 181 personnes
après l'activation vous avez votre
motivation
alors du coup on note quand même que
l'entrepreneuriat se féminise en général
quelques chiffres d'après l'insee 38%
des entreprises individuelles créé en
2012 l'ont été par des femmes
ces quatre points de plus tout de même
qu'en 2002 ça reste encore loin de la
parité vous
si vous avez connu des difficultés
est-ce que du coup vous avez été
considérés comme moins crédibles
peut-être non d'abord parce que quand on
dit j'ai pas été jeté comme ça d'un seul
coup dans ce monde là c'est à dire que
quand on a démarré en 96 l'entreprise
j'avais quand même carte blanche et j'ai
créé la majorité des produits et caetera
et j'avais moi-même en moi quelque chose
on n'était pas de conseillers extérieurs
mais j'avais un petit une petite flamme
à l'intérieur qui m'a toujours poussé à
créer de nouveaux produits à faire des
choses pour les enfants quand j'ai
attendu mon mon premier en 2000 j'ai
toujours eu quand même ça maintenant
oui votre question c'est est passé vers
la socialisation est vide et du coût des
batteries est en effet non je ne peux
pas dire qu'on me mette des bâtons je
peux pas dire qu'on met des bâtons dans
les roues parce que j'aimerais toucher
pas un caractère à ce qu'on me met des
bâtons dans les roues
comme je disais tout à l'heure en
coulisse s'il faut enfiler les bottes en
caoutchouc et enfilé un jeans par
rapport à part au dessus de la jupe pour
aller voir ce qui se passe sur le
chantier et ou sur avec les
entrepreneurs ça ne pose pas de problème
et ça me pose pas de problème de
m'imposer et c'est vrai que s'imposer
c'est peut-être un tout petit il ya un
effort supplémentaire peut-être à faire
une fin on remarque également fait que
finalement le secteur joue d'après
l'insee donc les femmes représentent 60%
des nouveaux chefs d'entreprise dans
l'enseignement la santé humaine
l'action sociale donc l'enseignement ça
vous concerne directement nous avons
rencontré une chef d'entreprise qui va à
l'encontre de ces données elles
travaillent dans un secteur plutôt
masculin je vous laisse découvrir son
portable
quand on arrive dans les locaux de sa
société où se mêlent plantes vertes
bougies et statuettes
on est loin d'imaginer le métier de
corinne cette femme hyperactive est à la
tête d'une société de déménagement un
milieu a priori très masculin mais pour
elle son statut de femme est plutôt un
atout
au départ c'est vrai que ce n'était pas
forcément bien ressenti mais aujourd'hui
le déménagement se féminise
à son grand avantage il faut pas oublier
que quand vous déménagez quand un couple
déménage une famille c'est bien souvent
madame qui gère le déménagement la
proche d'une femme sur une opération de
déménagement répond certainement aux
besoins et non exprimées parfois des
clients et ça mène effectivement une
touche plus personnelle
en plus de cette activité corps il
continue son premier métier hôtesse de
l'air un emploi du temps bien fourni qui
n'a pas empêché de prendre au fil des
années de plus en plus de
responsabilités
elle est notamment vice présidente de la
chambre syndicale du déménagement
d'ile-de-france et au début elle a dû se
battre pour s'y imposer
alors départ j'ai été perçu comme une
hôtesse de l'air qui se mêlent de quoi
de caisse
donc c'est vrai que il va certainement
fallu que je leur prouve quelque chose
même si personnellement j'en ressentais
pas le besoin
mais en étant naturelle et en défendant
mes idées je pense que
où l'on accepté la preuve iman élu à ce
poste à corinne ne s'arrête jamais avec
son associé et marie elle gère une
vingtaine de salariés réalisent mille
chantiers par an et se déplacent partout
dans le monde en tant que navigatrice un
mode de vie difficiles à conjuguer avec
vie familiale aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup
plus facile puisque méfient en 25 et 28
ans dans quel sens tu nommes elles
volent de leurs propres ailes
c'était plus compliqué quand il était
petit jeu notamment à cause de mon
métier de deux navigante c'est vrai que
je les ai pas beaucoup vu grandir ça a
été un peu le drame le manque de ma vie
certes alors il faut dire que corinne
gastaud est particulièrement occupés
nous virginie vivez vous êtes enceinte
de sept mois
c'est ça vous travaillez toujours oui et
pour vous donc comment vous comptez vous
organiser par la suite pour vous c'est
pas un problème
non ça se voit là c'est une période
effectivement ça nécessite d'être rude à
voir
de trouver des solutions mais je les
trouverai pour l'instant j'avoue que
j'avançais
j'ai trouvé quelques solutions qui me
permet de questions pour la suite
ce soir on comptait reprendre tout de
suite après oui oui je peux dès que je
peux alors vous vous êtes aussi mère de
famille vous avez trois enfants trois
filles et voilà qu'à 13 ans et puis des
jumelles qui emma et jade qui en neuf
ans ce n'est pas du tout un problème
c'est vrai que c'est une question
d'organisation faut pas pu finalement
vous utilisez manille votre statut de
chef d'entreprise pour mieux gérer et là
ça m'a permis de bien mieux j'irai je
veux dire
mon existence de maman parce que je fais
un petit peu j'organise mon emploi du
temps aussi en fonction de ce que je
n'avais jamais pu faire avant j'ai pu
aller les chercher à l'école des choses
aussi bête que ça
mais lorsque je voulais dire c'est
qu'une une vie familiale quand on est
chef d'entreprise c'est un plus
moi mon entreprise est florissante elle
elle dégage beaucoup de croissance on
est en plein boom et les enfants ne me
gêne pas du tout au contraire ils
génèrent de la créativité chez moi
hénart on espère en tout cas que ça
donnera de nombreuses femmes l'on envie
de se lancer
oui alors allée au courage deux femmes
et deux chefs d'entreprise alors au
niveau des conseils à donner
virgin effet vous serez vous venez de
sortir un livre voit la stratégie
marketing 2013 qui est un guide pratique
pour aider à se lancer dans le web
principalement c'est ça voilà c'est par
contre pour homme pour femme vous
conseiller pour tout le monde c'est pour
tout le monde et c'est un homme et une
femme qu'ils ont créé anthony guette je
veux que mon associé aussi qu'il l'ait
fait on a plus on a mis à plat tout nous
tous nos conseils toute notre expérience
à libre paritaire hommes-femmes
c'est ça pour les hommes et pour les
femmes clair on va continuer cette
chronique aequo avec l'info en plus il y
en a trois des infos et d'abord ces
entreprises yvelinoise qui mène des
travaux de coulisses du coup du court
suzanne lenglen sa tête et nice paris
voilà ce bien sûr deux entreprises
versaillaise participent à la rénovation
du court de tennis suzanne lenglen à de
roland garros
le cabinet d'architectes gérard d et la
marbrerie des yvelines
il s'occupe de la réfection des
coulisses du court comme les vestiaires
le club des loges où le salon du
président allez on va enchaîner
maintenant la semaine on nous avait
permis de l'extension du centre
commercial parly 2 et ben et oui il ya
du changement
voilà on vous indiquait la semaine
dernière que la commission nationale
d'aménagement commercial avait autorisé
l'extension du centre commercial parly 2
avec la création de la galerie ciel de
paris
c'était sans compter l'intervention du
maire du chesnay
les bâtiments étaient auparavant loué à
l'inspection académique de versailles
ces locaux sont toujours considérés
a des bureaux à destination de bureau et
non de commerce et c'est à la mairie de
changer ce statut
philippe brillault a annoncé qu'il n'en
ferait rien et demande une concertation
avec les habitants les commerçants et le
promoteur concerné marne et finances
voilà m la cci la chambre de commerce
par ile-de-france qui chiffre les
retombées économiques du supermétro oui
un bilan on vient de sortir et les
chiffres sont bons la croissance
régionale passerait de 1,5 à 2 % de 2015
à 2020 puis de 2 à 2 5% par an jusqu'à
le rapport estime par ailleurs à 60
milliards les recettes publiques
supplémentaires au niveau national j'ai
une question à deux femmes chefs
d'entreprises qui sont encore en plateau
avec nous le grand paris le supermétro
ce serait important pour vous ces
dirigeants phocéens c'est important
c'est un plus
c'est un pépin de plus et justement
ronan parle du grand paris je vous
propose de ce sujet sur les conséquences
notamment des yvelines après les
décisions rendues par le premier
ministre jean-marc ayrault grand paris
express est mort vive le nouveau grand
paris jean marc ayrault a donc tranché
mercredi oui le projet de transport de
banlieue à banlieue initié par nicolas
sarkozy verra bien le jour
mais il coûtera plus cher et les travaux
seront plus longs dans le détail deux
cents kilomètres de lignes vont voir le
jour ainsi que 72 gares
le coût global est de 29,5 milliards
d'euros contre 20 milliards initialement
annoncé le financement n'est pas
totalement finalisé il se fera par une
redistribution de certaines taxes
touchant les entreprises et aussi par
une contribution de plusieurs millions
des collectivités locales mais le
premier ministre a aussi évoqué la
possibilité d'augmenter les amendes
forfaitaires de stationnement et de 17 à
35 euros
concernant le département des yvelines
des ajustements été opérées sur le
projet initial l'ancienne ligne verte a
été baptisé ligne 18
elle reliera versailles chantiers massy
palaiseau en passant par saint quentin
en yvelines et ne sera achevé qu'en 2030
l'aménagement sera plus léger un métro
sur pneus un tram train et un métro
aérien
cette ligne 18 permettra en tout cas de
desservir saclay appelé à devenir un
pôle de compétitivité incontournable
avec ses entreprises et ses centres de
recherche et de formation
l'enjeu est de taille avec ses
réalisations le gouvernement entend
permettre à
région de rivaliser avec les principaux
pôles économiques mondiaux en réduisant
les temps de déplacement et pour finir
cette chronique et coplas maintenant
comme tous les jeudis à l'agenda
économique et on commence avec une date
en lien avec la journée de la femme
le conseil national a des marocains de
france propose une journée de débats et
de rencontres à mantes-la-jolie des
événements toute la journée dont un
débat avec aicha ech channa fondatrice
de l'association solidarité femmes
et puis le 12 mars vous pourrez assister
un atelier pour apprendre comment
trouver un emploi via les réseaux
sociaux se passe ça se passera par don à
la cité des métiers à trappes et enfin
dans le cadre de la semaine de
l'industrie le pôle emploi cadres de
guyancourt accueille les entreprises le
21 mars
il s'agit d'une réunion d'information
sous forme de petit déjeuner pour
découvrir l'offre de services aux
entreprises de pôle emploi mais surtout
un cv dating des cv seront sélectionnés
tout spécialement pour les entreprises
présentes
alors ce n'est pas pour tout de suite
mais il ne reste plus qu'un jour aux
entreprises pour s'inscrire à willer
faut donc pervis faut faire vite sert
son père pour cette chronique echos' 7 8
100 % féminin maintenant terminée alors
le mot de la fin est bien je me dis je
vais le laisser à un homme poète jean
ferrat qui a repris cette aide très
belle phrase de louis aragon
la femme est l'avenir de l'homme bonne
soirée et puis demain vous retrouverez
c'est louis fleury pour le 7-8 week-end
à très bientôt sur notre antenne qui
voit plus aucun horizon
et le futur et son royaume
vassal autre génération
j'ai déclare avec aragon
la femme est l'avenir de l'homme
entre l'ancien et le nouveau
votre but à tous les niveaux
de la nôtre est un division
dans les offres qui font les lois
sylvain chanté par mamour
d'autre part la nuit